[Music]
now come on let's be honest who doesn't
love a delicious chicken but what
happens when you get a whole chicken
cooked in literally 10 minutes well
please all of you watch carefully
because i'm going to show you how to
make a delicious spiced batch cup
chicken with a green goddess sauce
right oscar pan down please
baby chicken so spatchcock basically is
the back of the spine taken out and it's
flattened and we slice the legs the
drums
and that speeds up the cooking process
now the actual seasoning for this we've
got some garlic powder thyme smoked
paprika pepper touch of chili green got
a sauce green because it's got that
beautiful vibrant rich
incredible avocado in there buttermilk
tarragon mustard and some white wine
vinegar we're going to finish this with
a little sort of
creamy gorgonzola right let's have 10
minutes on the clock please let's go
now first off get your spices
blended okay pepper
okay salt
a touch of chili
from there
your smoked paprika literally
a teaspoon which stores the back of a
tablespoon for me
and then
a nice sprinkling
of dried thyme okay
and all we're going to do now is get
your chicken literally and stick that in
there
now when i say in i mean literally i
like to get this sort of marinaded the
day before because those spices
literally
turn the color of that skin beautifully
okay
now
let it sit in there okay
and then that smokiness sort of starts
to change
the flavor of that chicken
quick wash the hands
[Music]
now
from there get that grill nice and hot
okay
and the secret behind this is that we're
gonna flatten the chicken out over the
grill skin side down first okay
there's the drums
dab dab dab into that seasoning
and
on she goes now don't you dare waste
that
season that on there like that okay
get that in and on cook with the
seasoning
quick wash the hands pop the cloth while
i wash my hands please
10 seconds
now
from there get rid of that board
you can press this which is almost like
a sort of brick chicken and you press it
and it caramelizes i like to actually
get a pan
fry pan normal pan and just put it over
and that starts to cook
the chicken quicker
just check the color okay
lift up
one side you start to see don't be
scared of all that beautiful
caramelization once you've got the
really nice color on there lift that up
okay
turn that over
and then literally open that back up
pan on
okay really important keep that pan on
it it cooks twice as quick
drizzle a little bit more olive oil on
there
okay and let that literally get going
okay now the goddess sauce this is a
beauty the ramsay household we use this
on fish chicken red meat and of course
white meat
first of all
a nice tablespoon of dijon mustard you
can use a english mustard but the dijon
mustard helps it become a little bit
more sort of
almost sweeter less spicy
followed by buttermilk
now that's the
beautiful
acidulated
yogurt and it gives a really nice flavor
to that sauce
fresh tarragon just get your tarragon
and literally hold up
and pull off
those wonderful leaves that gives it a
really nice sort of acidic slightly
spicy flavor i want to get those stalks
out so just hold it up and peel off
those little leaves fresh tarragon
really helps lift the sauce
and literally helps with the color as
well and then from there
literally get your avocado
okay
in
open that up and look at the shape of
that
that should literally fit the spoons so
get your spoon in there
i need to peel it and just go up
and in okay
now
a nice tablespoon of cider vinegar
okay and now we're going to blitz that
on
literally 10 seconds
take that off
give that a good shake
and again
beautiful
tap it
and then look
most beautiful
amazing
vibe sauce that goes so well
with that chicken
now
look under here
[Music]
you see what's happening
but
here's a little tip
get your jug
and just literally place a little bit of
water
there
oh what that does
it sort of
steams the chicken as well it's a really
cool technique just make sure you've got
the extraction on when you do it right
now
from there
lift that lid off
and look that chicken cooks so
beautifully
look at that
back on
underneath
time please
four minutes to go and again a little
bit of steam in there
it works so beautifully it creates the
steam and
the chicken has been colored
it's got that wonderful caramelization
on there now that water in there steams
i've kept the gas up nice and high okay
now when we come to
finish this dish okay
that water will evaporate
okay
i want to quickly
just get some nice sliced bread
now look
i can turn that gas down now
and now it's steaming i'm going to use
this pan
[Music]
get that really nice and hot this time
okay that chicken is cooking beautifully
really really important if ever you're
in doubt
of the
thighs or the drum just take your knife
and just go through again you'll see
look those juices are clear
the breast is nice and plump and it's
cooked beautifully
the thighs of the drums always take a
little bit more but it doesn't matter
now turn the gas down we've steamed that
drizzle
olive oil
take your lemon
and just squeeze some fresh lemon juice
from that think of what's happening now
with a smoked paprika
squeeze and put the rest on there and
we're just going to grill the lemon but
squeeze the juice out of it first
squeeze
and then grill the lemon as well now in
this pan
i'm gonna make some beautiful croutons
okay and the croutons are gonna go well
with a salad
tablespoon of olive oil in there
time please
2 30.
right from there
it's a really nice sort of crusty
leftover
bread
and you know the best croutons
are always made with stale bread it
doesn't go off
it just gets drier therefore they get
more crispier
nice big chunky croutons okay
get that oil nice and hot
and then literally in we go
we're gonna sort of toast these now
beautiful
okay
a little bit of salt
a little bit of chili okay
and get those
croutons nicely toasted
now here we go is there toasting
start dressing your salad
okay
i've got my fresh gorgonzola
and all we do here is just put a little
touch of salt
a little touch of olive oil
and
a fresh squeeze
of lemon juice okay and that's going to
make it a little bit more sort of
vibrant up
but before
we roll it around dressing just break
off the gorgonzola
okay
and just sit that in
and look
you don't want to make any pretty
pictures with this salad it's a sort of
rustic delicious salad croutons are nice
and crispy
that
is gonna sit beautifully
my place
one minute left
and then with the avocado
out
get your spoon
in
round
over she goes
and then literally just
slice that down
and sit that
on top of your salad beautiful
boom
and then look
lift that chicken up
she sits on there
my croutons
go on
so crispy and then finally
10 seconds
and then finally
my lemon
sits on there as well this could be
squeezed on
and then finally
boom
on and there you go an amazing
spatchcock chicken grilled beautifully
with an amazing green goddess sauce
done in 10 minutes
[Music]
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intend if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsay and
10 cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you want to come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck
you